[Music]
good evening all right
i will open the meeting
we're all here so there's no apologies
public forum
um
tim is here for the deputation but
there's no members of the public for the
public forum
all right
well we'll put him in now
we can just move on to okay move on
and move on
we won't fit perhaps he doesn't
suggestion
no we can just yeah he's not doing it
are there any conflicts of interest
well before we carry on this is being
live streamed to tonight's meeting
confirmation of minutes
the fourth of august meeting
somebody moved are there a true record
please
thomas seconder
mark thank you all in favour
matters rising
tracy
what was the outcome with um laurie
richards after the last meeting
thank you
and item
number nine the signs
for doll control on the ohio stream
walkway i think you were looking at that
one it was a year or two
um through you mr jefferson um
grant actually did deal with that and we
did send a
response to council meetings about the
signs
so that has been dealt with
are the dogs able to understand it as
well
i hope so
right
moving on deputations and presentations
tim
you're on
all right
uh good evening everyone um
yeah my name's tim fulton from west
i came here this evening and i'll
firstly i'll just circulate
just to illustrate
the point i'm making
i live opposite the the west denton hall
and growing up in the west hitton uh
swami area that my
parents from farm frontage was on north
air road and i admit personally i've
always been fascinated and
in the history of the of the railway
lines that originally went past here
went from
ring euro to oxford we've all seen the
railway sightings and the remnants are
there
the few of them that are there now um
i often in the course of my my work and
just for a bit of downtime
go down north there road and i passed
one of these uh turned old termitable
areas opposite the
west denton hall
but the particular point i'd want to
raise here is there's a mound there that
was a remnant of an old railway
station if you call it that uh well in
fact it was quite a building
i've noticed
in recent times
that this particular
innocuous looking feature that you see
there
is basically been being trampled and
distorted largely by cattle movements
down the far you know down the road
and i understand that dairy farmers have
got to make a business got to make a
living
but to me at it seems that
waimakariri wide
we could actually take some simple steps
just to protect some of our our heritage
features here
whether it be a mound like this
whether it be a railway siding
some relic down here at a hoka
just a little bit of fencing
a little bit of signage
and just take a little bit of care to to
protect these features
this this particular one you'll see
look it doesn't look much does it
but
all we always need
four plates two bits of wire all the
farmer do
let's just let's just protect this
feature and just to give you some
context here i understand that the
neighbor of the property
who actually has the the turntable
siding area
like so mark would be well aware of this
for some years he's actually been
putting some fencing in
and he has a project of some sort to
install a carrot carriage or
um
and actually do quite a bit of work at
this west end hall area so
so if we see a bit of a big picture here
uh
what steps can the community board take
to just to just to protect
this this feature
um
just give you a bit of an idea we're not
all trained buffs
but
i want to read a little bit of extract
uh of what this
means in terms of heritage right through
waimakariri this applies to other
railway remnants uh
the establishment of the road board
and the opening of the school
met the primary local needs but
communication with the outside world was
very difficult
to get to christchurch where even
rangiora or kaiapoi was a major
undertaking we're talking about the
1870s 80s here
a railway would solve this problem
a branch line from kaiapoi through ahoka
and over the mandeville plains was open
to west ham
on december 27 1875 this was extended to
join the
the oxford branch at bennett's on
february 1st 1878.
um and you can imagine there's all sorts
of goods that that
were thus conveyed
the opening of the railway had a
considerable effect upon the developing
district
the most important factor
was of course the carriage of stock and
produce to markets and to ports
it also made it possible to travel
further afield at greater speed and more
comfort than a horse provided whether
ridden
or driven
and it goes on to talk about you know
the effect they've had
sure it closed down it was probably uh
it was actually a sort of a political
whim of the day it was probably in some
ways a form of institutional craziness
that there were ever two lines that went
out there
uh
in fact
some of you may be aware that at west
yetton itself
it was subject to probably the um
one of the most rambunctious
council meetings you you'll ever see
uh there was a quite a spat between the
the rangiora factions and the earthen
factions they all met at western they
had a meeting
the vote to
to run the line from rangiora to oxford
was briefly overturned there were people
climbing in and out of windows the
virtually fist fights
it's it's fantastic story of local body
politics
um if you ever care to read it uh
so
it just seems a shame to me that sort of
big picture that we can't take some
small steps to at least protect some of
our little bits of heritage that we do
have along these lines then
and i suppose the final point
i'd make is that i i do know that uh
living in the area there's actually a
lot of people who
you know of an afternoon or a day that
they go up walking biking
they stop at these little areas and
you know what would it really cost
to take something from the council
records put up a sign
and just create little points of
interest in these rural areas um yeah
just
it's it's just another little amenity
for for rural communities so
so i just want some um
hope you can take that into
consideration and uh
and
support some sort of first steps to uh
to preserve an area like this
so thank you
are there any questions
right
first off tim thank you for taking the
time to come down here and tell us about
this um as it just so happens we have
been kind of on the hunt amongst us for
possible
landscaping um
projects in the in the ward for the
upcoming year so your timing couldn't be
better yeah
now i'm not
promising anything any any one way or
another but but um can you tell me is
there anything at all marking this site
at all does it anything to
to see what it is
no no nothing of that nothing on that
mound um
yeah that's only actually a few days ago
i was talking to another neighbour and
who pointed out that
of the the private land owners plans so
if even half of his plans go ahead then
um it'll become quite a nice little
feature just to opposite the western
hall there so
uh
yeah one of the things i didn't point
out is actually a lot you know for an
area like ours quite a few people go to
go walking down that road
and
you you can imagine
in the middle of winter people running
their dairy cows
you know
down that road it's just disgusting
uh so
i'm not asking for that particular i
know who probably heard the particular
farmer is
not asking them to change their farming
habits but all we need some wire around
it
and take the cows around it'll just make
more pleasant sort of area
yeah would would you take it as is
being adequate at all to have something
sort of like down mill road here where
are you aware have you ever seen the the
wilson's mill siding um historic place
there's there's a stone set there you
know as we've got around the district
that sort of just denotes what it is and
i think i think something like a stone
or a gray you know a brass plate or
something like like that something with
a little bit of permanence would
probably be adequate um a similar
feature for instance um
on on
tram road near the browns road corner
that's the motorcycle you know heritage
sort of site or something so
um
i know they're in west yet and for
instance
like it was durham
kingsbury he's got about 30 different
points around the area in fact i think
he's done a lot of work mapping
different areas
a lot of them are pretty innocuous you
wouldn't know you know what what it was
or where it was
but perhaps perhaps if we just light
this off a little bit so we could have
more signage you know to some of these
historic areas um
we do have a very interesting real
heritage around through here
particularly with that line like just
on the corner of bradley's road and mill
road
and also at the top of bradley's road in
tram there are platforms of the old
railway stations and whatnot yeah on the
platform bar itself is fantastic in
there quite exciting that's you know if
you did half of that in that area and uh
that that would be that would be great
um
the the other aspect i suppose there's a
linkage there in terms of uh
west yet and there's
there's that you know the actual rail
trail if you call itself and the
pathways are great you know my kids go
to school up up and down that pathway
um i think it's just probably just
another collectively another reason that
which actually just um
take a little bit of care for these
railway sightings i mean north aurora's
got a great sighting
oxford ranger is a bit the same um you
know we've got to we've got to preserve
some space for these trails for people
to bought the bike and walk and
yeah just thanks
yeah this land's still part of the
railway reserve or is it private
property
uh no it's well that's it's roadway
siding it's public as public land yeah i
know um
yeah and this is a bit of anecdotal
feedback of this neighbor who
had a little talk to the to the dairy
farmers and first thing they said oh
well it's public land you know as if to
say try stopping me
um this shouldn't be an issue about acts
of about private public land it's just
it's not really going to get in any ways
away just to fence it off a little bit
or
um
yeah thanks for that tim i understand
you've written a book on the history of
the area is that still available and
where would you get it oh yeah yeah
i didn't come here for that reason yeah
yeah i have yeah
kiwi farmer's guide to life so i mean
that that that actually covered a little
bit of local history
um
yeah uh a part of that actually just
part of my but a bit of the context here
is that
i've been looking at all these local
sites on um
i've tasked myself with writing their
west denton school's 150th sort of
history or updating it next year
and so that's how i encountered likes of
bernard and some of his research and uh
yeah and found some of these little
sites that uh
i'd say um
so the being a newbie to the area i'm
quite interested in the uh history of
the area um there must be a number of
places of historic interest not only the
one in west hampton but
uh around mandeville where i am
currently living yeah are you able to do
a summary of of uh historic places of of
interest well actually the the i know
the
pamphlet i've got at home some of you
may have it's uh it's a walking trail to
waimakariri
um
i think it was in collaboration with the
rangiora museum and
uh that's that's a great one because
here it is little pamphlet
uh i think we've got about six or seven
different areas through wymac
uh a little map 20 points in each area
i mean
if you want to just go for a lazy walk
or a ride around your own area it would
be great it'd be you know it's a great
way of actually just following it
following it around um
yeah so and then that that particular
document includes uh old homesteads and
things obviously
private access but
um
yeah yeah so so there's been good some
good work being done
keep up the good work tim
thank you thank you tim um just
wondering
this area here it was a deciding so it
wouldn't have had a big sign on it
saying
we're staying
oh that particular that mound is where
the station was sorry but i think is
there a picture there on the side well
you've got you've this one here just
quite quite understand oh no no so
that's that's a close-up that's actually
just close up that just shows the
trampoline yeah of that mound and
particularly the tyre tracks and yeah
yeah
yeah just for example um
probably about 20 meters sort of you
know further further east
just over the fence there's
there is the the the siding there where
they understand this gentleman's got
plans
um there to put up a railway feature in
there so
so it was all linked together presumably
it was like it was a reserve
um when it's
as you know it's got big big wide
sightings it's a good walking area and
it's coming busiest so
now why i ask the question is um
at bennett's there's the we've just
council has actually restored some of
those signs and there isn't one or two
signs that have been restored yeah so i
just want that's why i need to know if
this was yeah
it is
yeah so you've got one there already
oh okay all right yeah okay
yeah that's right questions answered
do do you know when the railway line was
closed
uh
yeah
let's see
yeah 1919
the line continued to be used until 1954
for the carriage of stock producing
goods
uh
yeah and i i
it was it was closed progressively i
think one of the earlier ones was from
horrible to to bennett's
and then i think the last one was it
used to run about once once or twice a
week
um
yeah until the perhaps into the late 50s
so um
it is so it's
i suppose you'd say from a heritage
point of view with it
it it's
it's actually it's a it's a remnant of
sort of the
changing times in this in this area i
mean the way that had disconnected some
of these areas with the west ends the
horrible air wars
actually were and that they they did
rely on these railway platforms
um
world was a different place i suppose
i am actually
on a property down bottom in the mill
road here
the railway line went through our
property
and i was told when we came here 20 odd
years ago that
the line closed
down this end anyway 1964.
that yeah i have seen that those sort of
figures yeah yeah that would be right i
think so
yeah
mark
yeah thanks tom as you know i'm
passionate we see it in person as well
um i see you'll leave mr chairs not much
of a question for tim but
if you're at the crossroads at western
you know we've got the west end hall
which is a
beautifully restored historical
pride in the community
we're doing work on the oak reserve
across the other side and we've got oak
trees that go right through to
my boundary on the other side of the
water unit land which is historical
trees
so you know this crossroads that we
stayed has got quite a bit of historical
value to the community in terms of and
the linkage up to the school so
i was working from home
monday
probably a thousand cows came down the
road in one herd um milk tankers and
one-end trucks at the other end took
about half an hour
it won't take long with intensification
of the as we're seeing now that this
will eventually be eroded away
oh yes it's only um
it it's actually i should say it is
partly outside my parents base back at
what sort of further along north air
road
there isn't much of a stretch there
uh before it's going to be all tar
sealed and that will that will transform
that that road again it'll be difficult
job to do
whoever takes it on it's a twisty sort
of s-bend and difficult jingle but i
increasingly there's a lot of traffic
going down there so those uh and all the
way down north here road so those
those road sightings become more more
valuable
um yeah so so it's just worth with
probably bearing that in my in mind that
she will sort of protect these
um and i suppose the other feature is um
just in support of my argument if you
like is that i am i'm sure that there's
a lot
fewer people actually biking down tram
road
now for instance than they ever used to
uh for a time there it was a it was you
did a full loop from some people went to
christchurch and back and
and
and i think a lot of people have been
put off using these main you know trip
tram road for instance
they peek out and they're probably going
to be looking to to actually
literally go off the track
and and use some of these side roads and
i see a lot of people in our area just
doing biking
sometimes sort of 20 30k loops
so um
yeah just be a nice place to stop
so thank you there
thank you john
we will see what we're gonna do for you
well we're not just for you for the
district yeah
much wish happened thank you
right there is no adjoined business
move on to reports
grant
the west oxford reserve toilets
at the end of this
you may wish to talk to us
um
about what we were going to do in the at
the end the landscape budget projects
if that was okay with the chair i'd
certainly appreciate that
yep right so
um yeah first off um
this report on west oxford reserve
toilets
um i'm gonna keep my uh review short
because otherwise my glasses will fog up
and you won't be able to see me so
um
yeah so we
um in the long term plan there has been
provision for
a toilet block in the west oxford
reserve
um that was quite out
i guess a way out in the long term plan
and then um it became apparent that the
government has been
putting out what they call tift funds
which is a tourism infrastructure fund
and that is a fund specifically to help
i guess drive
tourism in new zealand and providing
locations for tourists to be able to use
that are of a good quality that
encourages
people to visit our country and and tell
the good news of what it's like to other
people encourage them to come
so
um we have previously done a um toilet
at saltwater creek um using that fund
and that was a really successful project
where we went half and half of the
tourism infrastructure
and
we did a similarly applied to that fund
um to see if we could get some money
towards the west oxford reserve toilets
on the understanding from council that
if we're successful with that
application
that they would allow us to bring that
budget forward um so that we could have
the time frames would align um to be
able to do it so
we put in an application
um the government were a little bit
sneaky and they gave us five days um
from when they sent out the application
to when they needed it
um so unfortunately we couldn't follow
our normal process which would have been
to come to the board get a plan approved
for what we're going to do and then go
to the application so we put the
application in
um and included in that the master plan
which is in your report um as an idea of
what
we were hoping to do there what it would
look like
so as part of that we asked for money
towards
a two bay drive vault toilet system so
there's no power or services on site
which means that um the toilet obviously
won't have
those services so a drive-off pretty
much means it all gets captured into a
tank and then we we come and empty that
tank as required
um and we have
because we don't have water there we
have um sanitizer station which you can
wash your hands or clean your hands off
i guess if
but also bearing in mind most people
that have got camera vans have got
facilities to wash their hands
themselves
and in terms of lights um it would have
a solar panel um and be be lit um
and yeah able to be used um at night
obviously um
so we put an application
and um we're successful in getting the
money from
the
government's tourism infrastructure fund
so the next step is for us to
get some i guess board approval to
of the concept plan of what where we're
wanting to put it in and what it would
look like um so that we can then um
go ahead and implement it we
i was hoping to be at your last meeting
and but unfortunately due to our
lockdown that got
pushed out
so
in the interim because we have to
part of the stipulations of governments
fund is that we have to have everything
consented and approved
and ready to pretty much ready to build
um by
six six months after them saying you've
got the money which hits right around
that christmas period when everyone
stops and hit the stuff so
um we have to get i guess approval of
things before that december deadline so
um
we have actually
gone out to tenders to try and find a
contractor who would
um
be able to provide the tool and install
it and what we're looking from you is
i guess a review of that uh
plan um to hear what you think about
what where we're going to put it and
what would look like
and whether there's any changes we need
to make to that plan
um
i'll also note
in terms of the plan that we've
obviously put facility in there for the
toilets
a little bit of parking and a bit of
planting around that um that would link
in
the same sort of planting that's already
been done on site by keep oxford
beautiful um we're also looking at using
some of that but that budget to
fix some of the potholes in the existing
track and um create an
additional loop track um so just come
out from a track and background um in
the i guess you'd call it the southern
corner
that's shown on that plan um
so yes um
we have spoken to ecan
um regarding it and they are comfortable
with the location um and in particular
referenced um comfortable around the
height elevation because obviously it is
right sort of on a not a plane beside
the air river
but they were comfortable with the
height of that
and added that they believed that
actually having facilities here was
going to be beneficial because
it stops pollutants and stuff from being
put in the river if there aren't
facilities provided so
um
yes uh i think that's probably enough
from me
um and you're happy to answer any
questions you might have
don't get
um thanks very much for this this is
this is good news isn't it
but look at a long time coming to the
couch so the community board
unfortunately
um just
clarification you've said there's no not
going to be any water and originally we
did talk about having a tank that could
be filled every so often for hand
washing but obviously that's
the um
yeah so stuff was just going to be there
for that reason then
there's no reason why we can't explore
that um that
may increase uh well probably would
increase the budget so we'd have to work
out what stuff we might take out of that
i guess um
saltwater creek
as you're unfamiliar with salt water
creek um rest stop um that was instilled
in well mid to end of 2019 and
it similarly doesn't have any services
there okay so we've just got the
sanitizers um station that seems to be
working really well that's right and we
haven't received any complaints or
concerns around it
um so
we kind of felt that that was probably
sufficient um for for what's there um
but i can certainly we haven't priced up
what it would be to add another tank um
for water storage um we would probably
if we did that
we probably still would retain the
sanitizers um just in case someone came
into the tank was empty for some reason
at that point
but it certainly can look into that oh
well we'll just i'll do that with the
oxford
community
board for that for them to consider
down the track
i've got three questions actually
um
because it's crown ecan land what
approach have you made to them about
helping with maintenance etc
ah yes that's a good point um
we we haven't spoken so he can um
these reserves have a very strange sort
of relationship where yes it's owned by
crown and ecamp and it's often it's
managed by us um
because i guess he can and their view
they have they would be happy to
leave it as farmland and lease it out or
whatever they don't have a great need
for it whereas
as council we've decided this is a great
spot for people to stop and so
we've kind of created a relationship
with them that allows us to use it for
that
use so
we can certainly have that question for
them and say look are you would you
happy but they likewise could come back
and say well actually
we don't have really an interest in that
um so thank you um
and how often will um it actually be
maintained et cetera because it's a
little bit out of the area
and what is the ongoing costing to
actually maintain it
yep um so
in terms of how often um and and the
costs are i can't actually answer that
offhand um i can certainly find that out
um
it would i can say it would be mainta it
would be cleaned regularly um and
and in short it was empty empty
regularly with saltwater creek we
um
did a little bit of a i guess trial by
era to start with just to see how much
it would be used and then within about a
month we had an understanding of
approximately after needed to be cleaned
and
um how after the tank needs to be
emptied and things so
obviously that's seasonal um and it's
also determined by how many people are
using that particular road and
and then on top of that how many of
those people are self-contained versus
um wanting to use it and bearing in mind
it's not just the campers who would be
using the torches of a day trippers
people from oxford who might be entering
the riverbed so
um
a little bit hard to say at the moment
but um it would i i can say we would
ensure that it was cleaned to out so
we've got a level of service in terms of
cleaning so it would be cleaned to that
level wouldn't be left to
um keep growing but i can't say how much
that would cost stuff thank you my last
question is just about the maintenance
of the track it is you just about lose
your car in it
so why wait till you get money from here
to actually
maintain the potholes in the track
that's already there
very good question also
um in terms of the maintenance of that
track um that's how organized by
operations team i'm not sure
where
they have their budget is sort of i
guess arranged by um
necessity around which one where things
are worse i don't know where this sits
on on that
while i was out there visiting the site
and
looking at where we would put a toilet i
thought you know what actually
why not apply for some budget for the
track as well so that's how that got in
there i thought if we can only ask them
the question if they give us some money
that's a bonus for us so um they said
yes so that's good because um
beautiful members are quite concerned
about the
the state of the trade
and it's been like that for quite some
time
so can it be put on a maintenance
um
schedule budget for ongoing
um i imagine so what i'll do is i will
talk to our operations team who organise
that sort of maintenance and just check
where that is and get them to get back
to you on that thank you
any further questions
right
okay you move on to your next subject i
think you might have to
oh sorry
you got a bet
yep
seeing that
so you're up
in your discussion
all right all in favor say all right
against
carrie thank you
[Music]
um
mr jefferson can i just say
members will notice that the
speaker system sometimes flashes if
you're not speaking
we heard people testing it they say it's
when it's looking for signal so if you
just ignore it it will find itself again
and then switch itself off
so it doesn't mean that your battery is
flat or anything like that it's on it's
literally just looking for wi-fi
if members would like the public has
left so you can take your mask off if
that would be more comfortable for you
is
thank you so um
thank you very much for letting me
proceed straight into the general
landscaping update
or budget
i think most of you are familiar with
the process um of of how we do that
pretty much the board comes up
with ideas
let us know we come to you with a report
on outlining all those um i guess the
positive negatives the costs all that
kind of thing the board makes a decision
and approves budget and then we go ahead
and try and implement it um
i would like to start by thanking your
board because out of all the boards
you're the board that has come back with
actually ideas
so thank you very much for that it's
really appreciated our end because it
means we're not going into the dark and
or having to kind of pester for ideas so
that was fantastic to get a flurry of
emails of different ideas from the board
so thank you for that um
so
um obviously we don't have a projector
or um anything to do a powerpoint slide
so i've just printed it off for you and
i apologize um some of the words wording
is a little bit small so i'll try and um
where it is explain what it is um yes so
you know how you know why um from the
some of the projects we've done in the
past
um few years so we've we've installed
the bike stands at oxford um we've done
some work down at the oxy reserve
there's a little bit left to do there
but it's certainly looking great and
really being appreciated by the
community
we've got a seat on an oxford main
street
um and
we put some money towards the bollards
at mandeville sports centre um
so that's a few of the
i guess good news stuff you've done
there's also a few projects that are
kind of still pending or in the pipeline
such as
um the oak reserve um in
west eaton um and you like i said the
the remainder of the stuff at the oaks
um in oxford um
in terms of your budget what you've got
available um you had a carryover of
2890 from last year's budget um
that some of that was unallocated some
of that was savings um on other projects
so the main street seat we actually
saved about 1 050 i believe from that so
that got put back into your budget
um you then had a budget allocated this
year of twelve thousand seven hundred
and ten
um and since that point you
um allocated the budget to the bollards
and mendel so um you'll see um in the
remaining column there's 9210 from that
budget to allocate so all up you have
thirteen thousand one hundred and fifty
to allocate towards projects in this
financial year
um
before i move on any questions around
that budget side of things
reasonably straightforward fantastic
um so in that case we will get into some
potential projects that have been um put
forward so
um
we had a suggestion of some putting some
money towards the ohio domain flying fox
um so just across the road the ohio
residents association has ever got that
right
by and large yep um
they've done so we identified a
um flying fox as part of the master
planning process for
ohio reserve hiker domain sorry but
there wasn't budget at the time to
actually install and so that's something
that's been picked up by the community
there's quite a lot of money has been
raised through the community to do that
and they're ready to kick off they've
got a contract ready to start i think on
the 15th
of um
november or october one of which um very
soon anyway
however that contract contractors looked
at the ground conditions and said
because of the waterlogged and the high
water table they're actually going to
need bigger foundations for the poles
which is going to add a bit of cost so
they
feel that they're around five and a half
thousand dollars short from where they
thought they were going to be um
have you spoken to them recently so is
this all new information because five
and a half thousand dollars is more than
i understood it to be requiring but i
hadn't actually heard about that the
extra foundations for the high water
table yes so that was a discussion with
rod buchanan yesterday okay
so he because whenever i spoke to him
previously like last week he was
thinking about a thousand yeah
so it's it's fair to say um they would
be really appreciative of of any budget
that was given to them because that's
budget they don't have to try and find
through community funding so and that's
one one project that um
has been put forward um
we also have a suggestion of some
additional landscaping um improvements
at the mandible shops um so potentially
some a picnic table um there are some
picnic tables there but some work around
that um some potentially some plant
planting
there was a suggestion of shingling the
car park i've just put a little note on
there um
the decision around
what that car park would be and whether
it would be shingled and things has been
dealt with by the board previously
through reports and decision making so
um
at this stage it's not out
we're not anticipating that that would
get shingled um there's also a bit of
concern i guess from green space's point
of view around the impact that they
would have on the root zone of the trees
um if we were to to make a real hard
stand above them um but it's an idea
that's come forward but um
platform has just changed ownership
and i um got accosted by the new owners
about the state of that particular car
park initially 12 months ago 18 months
ago we were told it's an
thank you and july
it became an absolute mess and all of
the shop owners were complaining about
the the mud coming through uh people
using that particular car park which is
an overflow car park were complaining
that it was difficult to find a car park
that wasn't under water there so i have
photographs but i that i can provide you
with but it's not suitable for
purpose only in the summertime when you
don't have rain
is it fine
can i ask a question what about mulching
it with
bath or something like that would that
help
i mean that would be all right for the
tree roots wouldn't it
um
yeah certainly seen that for um
mulch tends to float is the only thing
but yeah
that possibly could be an ideal worth
looking at um
i guess the the other side of this is
to sh
to shingle that is probably outside of
what
the budget you have in terms of general
landscaping so that could be something
that the board
could request
more information on and look to
including an annual plan submission
for specific funding towards it
the amount of shingles and stuff to do
that i think probably would put it well
outside the cost of doing that would put
it outside of what you've got available
in your general landscaping budget
um
but that's certainly something the board
could consider
um
yeah i haven't seen photos of when
when it was
that waterlogged i guess but i would i
would see it as a general maintenance
issue rather than something that would
come out of a board landscaping budget
so so that's um could be done i guess if
that was done as a service request to
green space um either by the shop owners
or by a board member and then we can
reply on how that might look or what
would go forward from that so
the dangerous trees that were there that
were leaning over like this have been
maintained and
chopped down and taken away they look
good
my understanding is that the the
graveled area there are no real trees of
significance which are
in the vicinity of that anyway so i
personally can't see why
or how gravel would affect any trees
there is a
a historic
tram line or railway line that goes
right through that which is quite
elevated
and that's the main access way that
takes you in but it slopes away on
either side and it's the it's the
low-lying areas where cars would park
that is the issue that would need to be
built up right wouldn't it to build up
much but it's just enough to
cause an inconvenience for anybody that
uses that
in saying that i understand there is a
resource consent from the owners of the
mandeville village to extend their car
parking on the eastern side of the
supermarket where they're looking
as part of their resource consent to
gravel that area and double the number
of car parking which may well mitigate
what we're talking about
i haven't been
privy to to what's happened with that
resource consent application but that
may well
solve what we're talking about
i'm certainly in favor of
some sort of landscaping in the
the old forestry reserve in the
mandeville area there where young
families can come and
sit outside in the sun
and uh take advantage of the
council-owned
barbecue tables that are
let's there
just to keep the board up that it's not
about the shed no the sheds being dealt
with separately yeah this is about
landscaping around the shed yeah so that
that's what they're looking for is some
funding like the border proof of swan
the cricket club
and the eaton pony club is the plant
shrubs and trees around the shed to
break down the hard lines of the shed
and the contour of the grounds that's
what
the rodeo club are looking for yeah
the shed's been approved by the
mandeville board yeah they've got the
funds to build the shed
sheds going up
they wanting funding from us under
landscaping budget for shrubs and trees
and natives
shed is only
four meters by five minutes it's not a
huge shed yeah
is
for them yes yeah they can apply for a
landscape fund and that's something that
we
that comes from us yes
but that's right but sorry
you know it can they can go into the mix
but you know step down to the mix
oh
my apologies are that was probably my
confusion created that i think it was
full of as opposed to landscaping
so
yeah so there is no just to clarify
there's no application process
for this fund for the general asking
fund um but it is i guess expected that
groups would come to you as their
representatives and you would bring
those two to the board so um when i so
when when i thought that this was a
project which um i guess in terms of the
shed um needed to go through the trust
first and that would have been a process
going that way
if they've already got approval for the
shed and for a bit of landscaping around
it then the board is within the rights
to allocate budget if the board chooses
to towards that planting
um
i hope that clarifies it and sorry for
that mistake on that um
hopefully i don't create added confusion
with the asphalt track um i'm not sure
if that has been through that group um
yep so so yeah so in that respect that
in that respect that would probably need
to go through the mandeville sports club
board and and then come back this way
yeah
fantastic um so yes they are the ones
we've got in front of us there may be
other ideas you've had in the meantime
um
such as sightings for railways or
whatever um
what i need from you is i guess an idea
of the ones that for you as a board um
you think yes that could be something
worth looking into further um
i can then bring a report back to you
with this is the cost this is what you
could achieve
um and recommendations and then you guys
go ahead and approve which ones you
think so um
yeah it's i guess it's up to you to have
a bit of a discussion um i can answer
where i can around which ones you might
be interested in pursuing further and
letting me know
[Music]
yeah i'd like to drag this back a bit
because i've been able to get a word in
if the as as ray mentioned the resource
content for a car park
being increased at the mandeville shops
can
grant you or w tracy
make sure that the
car parks are wider than they are in the
existing carpark
because there's been a lot of
controversy over
big vehicles parking and not enough room
please
[Music]
okay
i understand the resource consent
application was simply for
metalling the area and being metalled i
i can't see how it would be a marked car
park area in the first instance
it's just stage stage one of a future
development depending on a number of
of things including a proposed plan
change for the particular site
um
would you mind please just um because i
can't read your little print here those
little um purple color kidney things
shapes around there what is what are
they
so i guess they were just very broad
brushed areas that we couldn't oh okay
oh i'm with you right yeah yeah i didn't
know if those little blue ones were
actually sighted so yes
the blue squares are
um
possible burial sites yeah yeah um so
we've identified the right shape the
about the right depth
no no that's that's fine just it's just
a bit hard to read yes yes okay no
that's fine thank you i will ensure that
if the board wants to i guess
so how would we actually
just moving on how would we actually
define these areas would they be just
the wide flowers around there and and
it wouldn't have any
any edgings to it or anything like that
okay okay thank you
all right anybody any further questions
thomas
um probably more of a comment than a
question but um
uh
i
think that i actually the idea of a pump
track is an awesome idea um i tried to
reply to your email but it's just still
in my unscent box
um because i'm a bit simple sometimes
but um
yeah i think there's a great idea it
just would be the cost would be the only
whole drawback on it um and i think if
we somehow could get some contractors to
do it it'll be it'll be great i'd i'd be
happy to be part of it
um
i've done three this year so
um they're pretty popular at the moment
um and i really like the idea of doing
something in the mandeville village
reserve i i personally think it needs a
bit of a sign or something just to say
what it is there because it's a bit of a
just looks like a paddock with a couple
of trees in it so i'd like to see a sign
or something going there just
i don't know just to represent that it's
actually a reserve not to someone's
paddock so um
and i actually really like the idea of
the wildflowers at the
oxford cemetery as well that's a good
idea
um
with the our ash filter tracker in the
mandeville area
sort of
talking to ray about an idea and also um
i had a meeting with a group of kids at
this one and i was school as well of
things that they would be keen on in our
area and
that sort of project probably
i guess has to come through in a
different way um but potentially could
get a bit of funding from this but i
think that we've probably got a pretty
lucky pool of local contractors too that
would um likely pull together um and do
that i mean we got two on the board here
right now so um
that potentially could um
be a way of getting getting something
like that there because i think that
that would be a really great um
especially when they get their mountain
bike track going around i mean have a
hub there um for the kids to go to and
something to do would be
would be awesome and plus around that
mandible shops
just like what thomas said at the moment
it's a it would be a great little place
to go grab a feed of fish and chips or a
pizza from the um
from wherever
the platform and you can go out there
and sit out there so you know some
plantings or something to make it safer
for the kids to be there um
anything you know would be progress to
what it was so i think that would be a
real benefit and
um
bring that whole hub together as well as
a usable site
um
this one-on-one domain
is just a write-off really
it's just there's nothing i don't know
whether it's because the cricket
ground's taken over or what it is or
which part of it is
this one i know a domain which part can
we use it's just a very confused
space with a couple of old swings
so
that's probably it would be a great
project for
this one in our school to get involved
with and doing something
in combination with them if that was
something to happen but um yeah i'm
happy there's lots of great ideas on
here
thank you mr chair um
from my perspective i think that
i look at the first one from a high one
i think is worth getting a report on
um i think the um
this is so small even my glasses aren't
helping with us
um the second one the mandible shops one
i think yes we have talked in the past
about doing something more in that space
i'm supportive of that
uh the sauna domain one there used to be
a swanna
domain master reserve plan
that was developed showed the the
cricket club and what we were going to
do
and that that reserved draft was going
to go out for consultation it never did
so there's probably on file somewhere i
know that originally the roadside
vegetation trees were burnt down so they
got replanted the cricket club got
funding for some of it but that reserve
master plan was designed for the
community the school and the cricket
club and the whole committee to all
to do that through that process like the
west end domain one and so
the concept of doing something can there
should be i think be
a wider community involvement in that
one
um definitely i think the idea of the
report on the idea around the flowers
that oxford i think's worthy um
certainly the the mend of the not
mandeville sports club this is the uh
rodeo club the reason why there's very
little detail that we only had a meeting
with them three weeks ago and so they
only put them on to this potential
area of trying to get some funding to
help them with their landscaping
i can say that the mandible sports club
is working on a complete biking running
walking track right around its 80
hectare site
it's got that in its 20-year strategic
plan and we're developing that as
funding comes up from council and other
groups and help from local contractors
but that's a bit of a slow process
because there's lots of tree roots and
neighbours to consider as well around
that one so
that would be and again i'm not sure how
to handle tim's one in terms of
whether that
would be an idea to go into a report
for that pacific
historical site or that could be handled
differently from a different department
of council i'd
seek advice on that i'm not sure how
that could be protected
whether it's from this budget or
you know what can be done to protect it
so that's my thoughts anyway
uh he's just about the
oaks walkway with for us um i'm i'd be
very keen on the wild flowers keep
oxford beautiful has also indicated that
they would like
to do the bulbs and things like that
once we've got a proper plan
and they would really like to see it
quite english
and it's a completely different
um
thing than pearson park which they
consider that's to do with sporting
things whereas the oaks
is a lovely picnic area quite quiet
um i would probably i'd like to see some
funding to go towards the mandeville
planting
and
regarding tim's i think that's a jolly
good idea we don't know if there's
concrete underneath it or not probably
not
but the council does have funding in
their heritage thing
i would really like to see it
actually sort of fenced off or something
rather than a
than just a wee park and maybe a bit of
story about it because you go to other
other towns and you actually can read
you can actually read what it's all
what's what it's there for
thank you
yeah all right
[Music]
just in terms of
that mound on northeast road
i think protect it it needs to be
something quite strong
i've lost my box three times two
dairy cows
they rub against
so i think if you're protecting a
historical site like that it needs to be
stand up to a fair bit of pressure from
a large angry dairy cow
um
and the herd that came down today was
about a thousand cows um and so i think
it needs to be
something solid enough to protect it so
there's no chance that
staff will be going back every
every couple of weeks trying to put a
a white fence back up again so
that would be only my comment on on that
one but
yeah just very quickly um some of the
feedback from the um
local body
conference that i went to back in april
uh a lot of the community boards that
were attending that from around new
zealand got
far more involved in the actual projects
that they were funding i think we're
very fortunate here in that we have
contractors on the board as well
but the winning entry the winning um
a board
project from throughout new zealand was
from a little border the place called
ota rohanga which i think is on the
north island somewhere
and they had built a pump track which
thomas was referring to and now it's
world famous and note or a hunger for
their um
pump track and i think something like
that
would certainly bring them in especially
as these swannanoa to mandeville
cycleway is given number one priority
and we're going to have a number of
people coming to to do that cycleway
and uh to have something at the end of
it like a pump track and a
cycleway walkway right around the
mandeville village would be
outstanding for the area
that's all i've got
[Music]
just just a couple things
so do we have any kind of broad costings
yet or is the purpose of this with you
to work out things that we want you to
post on
okay
and also with regard to the heritage
items could we actually as a board apply
or
how i should know this but off the top
of my head i'm not 100 percent with our
hearing
if we could actually
apply for um
because there are quite a few heritage
sites around the district that have no
demarcation whatsoever
okay
as far as the the projects i think that
um
they all look
quite worthy
and um as far as the flying fox over the
road goes that's been in plans for many
many years my daughter's second year of
university now and she was a year six
whenever we started talking about
waiting for an awfully long time for
that
um
and and i believe that that all of these
other projects are also worth looking at
so but if if they're outside the scope
of our funding available perhaps we can
look at other other ways and also what
scope is there for us to use volunteer
labor
and
community funding and that alongside of
it
you
yeah so on that point i actually offered
to build some buns and pierce the park
around the um stage
for free it's going to take me like
three weekends and that
was labor and truck higher enough it
didn't free but it was next to
impossible in the end so i flagged it um
but um
on the pump track there was actually a
shirley might remember it was a pump
track beside the museum in oxford
um a few years
well must have been removed about 15
years ago by cancer when they extended
the car parked much to my dismay
um
but
yeah just just a bit of history there
because it was it was quite well used
and i don't know why it got removed it
obviously was just they wanted to use
the land for a bit of extra car parking
but
yeah it was a bit disappointing but yeah
the pump track's a great idea i reckon
my just my query was with the um
wildflowers at oxford i think it's a
lovely idea and would be you know
would be a vote for me but
um is there any scope of using any of
the funds already allocated to there to
because i'm sure that wouldn't be a huge
cost um could that not be squeezed in
with the
current funding
about the dog thing why are we putting
one of those in the oaks reserve when
you won't put one in
um the
eel air one
you know where are you gonna put the
toilets
i actually asked
and i got told no
so why are we putting a dog poop
station in the oaks
thank you
[Music]
joanne
okay
did you tell him to outrage you
yeah he just wanted to have the history
so both intersections
these controls
[Music]
no way that the vegetation can be cut
back can improve the visibility
in both
to situations this
um this is a
in regards to the norfair road one
did no one notice in preparing this
report that there's already a stop sign
there and there has and there has been
since they upgraded the intersection
well it's actually almost fallen over so
it's on a big lane
[Laughter]
doing a report
well we do need to go through the
process we need to make sure that we do
go back to the board and i acknowledge
it was done the wrong way around it
should have been done
um
all right
[Music]
yeah scott would you like to come
forward now
thank you
rubber um
which will be created on the property
which is 681 points road um would be
approximately eight we've got to be part
of the subversion
and um the road name the proper one was
right away now chosen by the developer
themselves
and i'll trust you the opportunity to
read my report and i will look forward
to any questions
please um
with it with the road names um has the
oxford ohoka
community board actually
made some suggestions of names to have a
list of names because i know there's
quite a lot in the other areas and i
think it's time we did
have us yeah
um
unfortunately
the community board thinking about
the the names of pioneers and such like
in the areas i think it's actually
really important that we really start
thinking about putting some names
together
to be used
through you mr chip
through you mr jefferson um scott and i
was actually discussing it this week and
we will the governance team will assist
the board
to draft a list and um
if board members can forward any
suggestions or any suggestions of who we
can speak to that would be highly
appreciated
when
this board was only an advisory board
there was a list
but i think it was actually a council
list rather than a specific board list
can you render my mark
[Music]
so we've named a couple of other places
in the last
five six seven years we've been given
um some research about
local
councillors from the air council or
principals or
postmasters of the local district we've
had some choices to choose from along
with the
what the developers put forward
i mean i could i tried to think look at
this because they said it was in
horrible which is a bit of a stretch
really it's on the other side of south
they're right here in towards the waimak
river it's probably in my main more more
way down air world area
but i got thinking about you know past
principles of you know the early first
principle of west end school there's a
nickname for that person
who are some of the early landowners
around the area as opposed to just
taking a developer snake name
so
i was just is there any urgency to
actually
do this tonight or could it lay on the
table for another month and we can
giving the board time to look at some
historical choices because again once
it's named its name and it's done you
can't change it
now it's it's i'd rather we again we're
talking about historical
sites trying to preserve them and trying
to recognize
our past in the local area as well so
um in any consideration
as well so yeah that's only my thoughts
you
he sort of answered my question because
it's only a private right away it's not
actually a road and i was just wondering
um eastwick are they the people that own
the land or they just the developers
he is
a developer
who currently owns the land
has he owned it for very long
[Music]
um i guess my point kind of is along
those lines too being that it's not a
significant road and it kind of is a
part of the history of that piece of
land that person with that name has
developed it so here is the history of
the development of that so
well the beginning of the history of it
so i don't know just an alternative way
to look at it
being
i've just had a thought maybe we could
call it the vic vicar
sorry
no he doesn't
i just want to make clear that i'm not
against that name being used but i'm
just future i think we need to actually
get our thinking about
our areas and our and our heritage and
history
some years ago there was a
road
off easter but road
that the people who developed it wanted
to use a family name and the board
refused and came up with a different
name
and in some respects
because this guy's using his own name
i'm it's not
perhaps acceptable
but we have
we're under pressure to make a decision
so
is eastwick the developer's actual
surname or is it just the name of the
company that he
owns um
okay thank you i would think just my two
cents worth that
if i can turn this into a question but
could we not
because this is just a private
right-of-way in in this particular case
go with that because titling is a time
is of the essence for them and
definitely i really agree that we should
look at having a bank of names for
various areas throughout our ward that
we can turn to because it does make it
easier for people when they are
developing
as well as you know and gives a clear
expectation i think of of what the names
should be
in character and and nods to heritage et
cetera
and also
um
it should just be
we we should really just have
have
something that
um nods to heritage so um with that
may i um move the recommendation
mr chair
mr chair may i move i would like to
remove the recommendation as it stands
i would like to move a b and c
[Music]
yeah i know you must have oxford names
and there must be some west heir to
names and i'm sure there's someone you
know like swannanoa
yeah
right moving on please
we've done last trade yet we go to
russia
item 7.4 the ev charger
i've got tia written down he's just told
me tracy
uh so obviously vanessa couldn't be here
tonight so i've said that i would um be
available without the huge depth of
knowledge but if there are any questions
you want me to check anything out i will
obviously this was following the earlier
report and feedback provided from the
community board about the location
and
looked to
meet that need and
all things being equal should proceed on
their basis and then unless something
unexpected comes up that causes it a
problem
so yep
happy to
take any feedback back or any questions
a question
about the lease that the farmers market
actually have and that there would be a
sign on the ev
stations to say that it couldn't be a ev
station on a sunday
that is a public car park and it's not
only used for the farmers market on a
sunday it's anybody can park in there
and they don't have stalls in there they
have them
on the fence
so i would
not like to see that's not a question is
it
is it
could we
not have a sign at
in all
yeah now considering that um i
understand his pressure we got that car
park sealed
um with your authority
right
uh just to say if i turned up with my ev
car on a sunday to go to the market i'd
have to park somewhere else
so there's no the recommendations don't
mention signage one way or the other so
they can
if you support them they can stand but
you could add another request that says
request that signage as da da da is you
know
uh following a recommendation
you know recommendations
[Music]
it's just
through you mr chairperson it's just
you note that it doesn't mean that
if it that they can't use it as as
charging base on a sunday we can take
out the whole of sea if you want it's
going to make no difference
there were some fish hooks in putting
this charging station in at the
originally proposed place in the oxford
town hall which required us to approve
additional funding
for it to go ahead
so
what then happens with that funding
should it now no longer be required due
to the change of a slightly more
appropriate location if it is found
in actual fact to be so
so in 6.1 it talks about that shortfall
um so that signal will be a funny
shortfall there's going to be six
thousand contributions of each um
meridian anticipate that it is still
required in the new location
so
so do we have recommendations are really
noting that the agreement and the
license to occupy
um
that there were nothing contravening
that that really the board's noting that
the licensed occupy works there but i
guess surely your point is talking with
the parties and
um making sure that it's clear about how
that works and
and that the signage doesn't
um wrongly depict what the situation is
as ray said it needs to be 24 7 so it
will just be an ev
um
charging point and people won't park
because it'll be painted blue or yellow
or whatever
and people will know not to park there
for a very very good with the eb
car parks
it gets clarified and that it's you know
clearly understood what the intent is
around that and talk to vanessa about
that so that it doesn't become an issue
probably just a question away around the
way the report's written because
item b it talks about
um
the location that was formally requested
by the oxford hoka community board and
that it talks about like that was the
town hall was the preferred option and
and it was my understanding that it
wasn't the town hall was the option that
was given to us because it wouldn't
require any extra funding
to install it there
um so we were forced into picking that
and that actually wasn't the case so it
probably wasn't our preferred option so
it's not it's not very clear it makes it
sound like we chose
that town hall site when it was
chosen because of the transformer which
was irrelevant in the end so not
it just
seems to be something that keeps popping
back up that it's out was our decision
to put it there when it sort of wasn't
so which paragraph was there
let's see i took that when i read that
that it wasn't
that there was informally request box
but hoka it wasn't that the original
location was that the alternative
location be considered that's how i read
that
yes
so i think you're right i think it'll be
clear but i think that's what was
intended
but take your point
um the
charging stations in rangiora
you have
one outside the
um the warehouse which is a prime
parking spot and i'm all always seeing
big four-wheel drives being towed away
from there because it is a prime spot
the one at the pack and save as part is
a way over in the corner where it would
probably be the last car park to be
filled up anyway
is it is there some way of
choosing a car park at the pearson
park
to be a least desirable one furthest
away so you wouldn't have problems with
locals with their big cars
no it's got to be a certain car park is
it
and is it a prime car park or is it a
they're all prime carpet are they okay
[Music]
and is it a fast charge
so it could take three or four hours
out on 20
because the one at the pack and save
um
takes us about 20 minutes
catch a movie
i just ask who's towing the um
the cars away i mean could i ring up
shane and get him to come along and
tow the car or how did how does that
work because we don't have
we used to have
yeah
um
enforcement effectively we don't do it
we don't do enforcement after hours
unless we specifically roster people on
there's an event we're going to do
random kind of reinforcement
so the parking team don't operate
outside of those hours if there is but
if there is so if there's towing
required that creates you know
a risk emergency blocking off pathways
or whatever
where there's a process to deal with
that but it's not done on a it wouldn't
i wouldn't envision it will be done for
overtime parking and
for ev stations or anywhere else
thank you mr chairperson 3u
board members will remember that in july
we
noted the budget that was allocated to
the board as well as approved the
criteria
for the board discretionary grants
the issue was raised
from
at some of the other community board
boards about applications received from
schools and the eligibility of schools
for grants
because according to some of elected
members
school activities needs to be actually
funded by the minister of education
this is a
recommendation
to
amend the criteria for the discretionary
growings just to make it
a bit more clearer
that applications from schools will will
not be considered but applications from
peer teacher associations and funding
committees or any other
group associated with schools will be
considered so it basically rules out
then the board of trustees of schools
applying
[Music]
during the last five years i we did a
quick calculation the oxford ohoka
community board received full
application from schools
which was all granted
but this is i just want to stress that
this is absolutely up to the ball to
decide
um
because every application needs to be
considered on its merit
and every
so
even if you you put this clause in your
criteria this is just a guide you can
still
make a decision contrary to the criteria
that you have
um it's
like i said it's up to the water design
thank you mr chairperson
[Applause]
from what i remember
two of those
school requests were from west edmond
school and they were both for library
books and their library is public as
well as school library
one was a hawker
for the 150th
anniversary
but the other one was i can't remember
it was the high jump yeah the high jump
right
throw a hiker again
all right
i think um generally most schools ptas
have a fundraising person so most of the
applications will come from the pta so
it would probably cover
that um i mean
the idea that the ministry is funding
schools is a little bit laughable but um
there's certainly lots especially in
higher detail schools they have a lot of
fundraising to get
to get funds to run their school so i
would definitely be in support of
supporting schools so if this is a way
to make it more helpful then
great
so just just clarification so if it
comes from a pta or any kind of
school group that comes to us
then we can consider those but if it
specifically comes from a school board
of trustees which i don't think we've
ever received anything from a school
board of trustees
then it would be declined is that the
differentiation that we're talking here
that's that's it or are there more
nuances to it than that that is
basically what it boils down to but it
doesn't mean it's been declined it just
this is more guide to the people who
apply them to the board
um
so
just to that they won't
i don't want to say be considered
less favorably
but just that the board will take into
consideration that they were supposed to
actually get funding from the minister
of education so for instance if if kids
were fundraising for a camp or something
yes or if
the sports team
you know sports
um equipment you know they needed
new uniforms equipment or something that
they couldn't otherwise get or what have
you in the sports coordinator comes to
the
board or whatever
those
will be favorably looked upon but if the
board comes and says
we would like funding to finish our
building project
we clearly say no thank you is that that
i think when i was looking at this and
um if i was in that western school and
i've been the board and board sheriff
like 12 years
um
if this come across my table i'll just
say to the board just send all your
applications to the friends of the
school and put it through them and
they'll donate the funding back to us
automatically
um so it's all it does is by default
drives the funding
from
the same app
um i think with the school for example
the library is not funded by the
ministry it's funded it was rooted
is the
by doing this is it making it easier for
schools to apply or is it just
so as it stands school shouldn't be
applying but they could apply if we put
this in
[Music]
that's a very hard
schools are already applying
this is an administrative tool
to bring the criteria
maybe or to guide the schools to be in
line with the criteria but like i said
it's totally up to the board
to to decide
if if the school comes even if the
school comes and say i want to paint
this wall then the board can use
the discretion to say yes or no
if you look at the criteria
it says that the board will only provide
funding
to
organizations community organizations
and non-profits
and a school is is not considered a
community organization and a non-profit
therefore
this is why the the
some of the other boards raised the
issue
that they want this
this in the criteria
but for me sorry for me personally it's
more administrative action than
narrowing the board's um
authority to consider a replication or
not
can we not just then add
schools to the list
and then use our
discretion to say yay
um i actually did question the wee
statin one because i believed you know
um books should be provided by the
school but once mark had told us what
happened at the west end school i was
all in favour um i'm not too sure about
the wording either
because there hasn't been very many
boards of trustees
that have come to to to us
it's normally been groups within that so
i was just wondering if it could be
worded a bit differently
through you mr jefferson um if the board
wish they can move a b and c and then it
remains exactly the same
then the the currently
sorry a and c
we don't have to change it it's a bore
decision
it's just yeah
may i test the meeting and move emotion
i was just about to propose that we move
a receives the report and c retains the
status quo for the 21 22 discretionary
grant fund application
criteria
my question to that would be because
they're not actually
listed in here to be able to apply for
the grant
then it doesn't make it very welcoming
to do so so
i can see why
maybe something needs to change in here
but whether it's just changed
differently to what's written here so
just say yes schools can apply
it doesn't have to be from a specific
group in the school
schools can apply for this funding
that's right i don't know if it helps
but my understanding is from the other
community boards it was around trying to
say to differentiate that the board of
trustees as you quite actually they've
got they get funding for things to
maintain their school to do those
activities but they want to leave the
door open for associated groups like
our ptas friends of board if you're
organising a jubilee so they're
distinctively saying hey that's that's
different that wouldn't be funded by
ministry so i think i think that was
some of the driver behind it but
absolutely tears right you could just
leave it as is
they
approving in the past um applications
from border trustees are we
not applying with the policy
no
they are just guidelines exactly tested
you have full scope so what it's trying
to do is give you give give you in the
community some guidelines but you've
always got scope for whatever reason to
say for this reason this reason we're
granting
please
i i think members should also just take
into consideration that we had four
applications in five years
and now it's it's the percentage is so
low that if we stick with the emotion
and the second that is country on the
table
it will be fine
that is correct
okay let's look at
using using b
and
applications received directly from
school board of trustees whereby being
directly funded from the ministry of
education
instead of will be declined
could be declined but we've got we've
got emotion on the table i know that but
if we can change them
yes
so i'll move an amendment that that
we reword that to could be declined
can we have a second
my amendment is lost
go back to the original motion which is
a and c
all in favor
against
carried thank you
[Music]
right correspondence is there any yes
oh yeah
[Music]
so
yes
there are still a couple of walls that
live in
i could literally january
um
a few doors down on the left side of the
white house
and um
[Music]
um
i will make sure they're there
don't get carried away
okay thomas is new
thomas
okay
all in favour
against
jared thank you
right chairpersons report
i attended a zoom meeting with a local
government new zealand on three waters
and thought that
the lgnz was some people were
for opting out and some were definitely
for opting in
the next day i attended the council
meeting
in renewab on the three waters
and
their
obvious opinion was opt out
there was
ages ago
and i had a north carolina neighbourhood
support meeting
since then
and that's about all that i've got to
report
thank you
somebody move that report be received
please
wendy
and
shirley
born favor
against kerry thank you
matters for
information
10.1 to
10.15
somebody moved that we received those
year marks second up
thomas brought him favor against
you
members information exchange we will
start with sarah
tonight
150th anniversary next year so i'm just
linking in with that group
around some community events
one of which it looks like with the oak
reserve planting i can update you on
there so we had some feedback from the
hall committee and the
steering garden club
so they've recommended that they prefer
that one of the large pine trees
gets taken out where the shrubs are
going to go
they will look asking question around
irrigation
pumping irrigation to the shrubs and
also questioned why the natives were
going further what we only thought i
send that feedback on to grant he's come
back saying the removal of trees
is under a 4d policy
i did say to the feedback group that
removal trees is a very highly emotional
topic that can take a number of months
to work through um
grants the recommenders that the tree
stays it actually does help with the
shrubs not take away from their growth
it's also that there is no power or
facility to
use articulated water even though the
pump is only 20 meters away from that
area so it looks like it would be
more the community lit by myself
in those early months we would be
bucketing water out of the water race to
get it going
it's definitely going to take the
feedback on board about cutting back the
number of grasses
um
but the school probably in the garden
club and the hall committee
we will probably have a public planting
day
and mulching day
now it's too late so it's going to be
probably april next year when the work
will be done
so because that's the the garden club
said they don't recommend we do anything
now there's too late in the year grant
probably agreed with that so the money
can be held over and we'll work towards
linking into the
150th celebrations of the school
um and the other thing i read in the
paper which i i wasn't sure i could
recall that
last week was that some commentary lee's
valley dark sky nature reserve i saw one
of the papers there's a group working
towards that and i hadn't come across
that in any of my
previous discussions here so i wonder if
anyone knew anything about it it was in
the
not the north carolina news the other
one that we get there
oh no it's in the north
the carolinas valley dark reserve song
so i was going to bring the cutting with
me but i'll take a shot of it and flick
it around the board but it's the first
i'd heard of it so yeah
that's all for me
um i met with
grant rayburn and
is it
or someone from green spaces at the
community gardens with because they're
still having
problems with vandalism and rubbish and
that
i spoke with grant today and the council
are going to put a
security light on the big pole
there
funding the managed to find funding and
it will also it'll go and they'll be
able to see the toilets and that as well
so that's really good
uh just let you know that the pearson
park advisory group has spent over four
thousand dollars
and planted beautiful azaleas and
rhododendrons between the old bowling
green and the redwood trees in mark if
you want a tree
blowing over two of our redwoods went
from pearson park so if you want that
pine tree
yes so and does everybody know that the
council have actually put out the
consultation for the speed limits there
hasn't been very much at all
um out there so i don't and they're only
given just 20 days for people to
actually respond to it
that's me
two weeks ago regarding the proposed
district plan
i also attended the
mandeville sports centre agm which was
on the middle of
september
and
i'm pleased to say that mark brown our
very own mark brown was
voted on to the board as a full voting
member so well done mark
we did have um
a big discussion at the agm on
what's happening with the um
mandeville sports centre some of the um
elderly members were a little bit
concerned that uh especially with the
new uh plan which i think is a is a
great um uh plan for the extension to
the um to the club rooms but uh there
were one or two that were um a bit upset
in the way it was going and in fact they
they thought it was becoming more of a
town and country club rather than a
keeping up the flavor of being a
a sports club
i noted that there were a number of in
fact i had a delegation of of a few
people that came to me from truro place
which had joins on near the entrance of
mandeville and they were concerned that
they were that they were only given two
days notice that all the trees along the
entranceway were due to be chopped down
and that the changed shores were about
to be started up that was two weeks ago
the trees are still there i did ring
grant from um green space but um left a
message and i haven't heard back yet so
uh be entered really good to have some
sort of consultation
between the sports club and the council
and the local people who live adjoining
that apparently there was one member
of the public who complained about the
trees and so as a response the council
are looking at cutting down a number be
a shame because the um the sports
grounds there do really need those tall
mature trees it is an emotive issue and
especially the cricketers when the
northwestern blows to have those trees
down would be a real shame there's also
a number and they brought this to my
attention as well a number of public
walkways and cycleways that some of the
developers who have built around the
edge of the sports center have left so
that people can i can can gain access
onto the mandeville sports centre and
over lock down i did a lot of walking
around the edge and noticed that there
were a number but they all seemed to be
fenced off and when i mentioned it to
the manager richard he said that it's a
council concern so again i left a
message with grant you know can we have
these opened up so that
people can gain access either by bike or
by
pedestrian access especially as there is
um
a considerable sum that the board have
there to be able to complete a cycle way
around the around the edge and
members of the public would welcome
having having access there not only just
through the the two main access ways
the district plan the proposed district
plan
is um is out there and um we had a
number of uh neighbors of mine who were
very keen to
discuss that at the ohaka market last
friday and turned up only to find that
it had been cancelled they weren't sure
why
but it was
it was cancelled and at this stage
mandeville and ahoka and swananoa a very
large area don't have any forum at this
stage for um discussion apart from
one meeting i think it's about a few
days away from the end of of the
submissions and i know a number of
people in
mandeville are very keen on putting
submissions in around the proposed
district plan
quite a few are in favor of it and quite
a few aren't in favor of it and they
just needed to be able to
discuss that so i guess the only other
alternative is to
go down to oxford or up to oxford or
head into rangiora
yes tracy um and i will just check but
my understanding was we were asked not
to attend the hoka market because of
their spacing or there was some issue
that we were asked not to attend
yeah yeah because they wanted to keep it
for still holders
yeah also next friday there will be
well it's quite tightly packed um over
the winter
it only meets on on the actual car park
so they have a reduced number of vendors
and they're they're wall-to-wall
and with the social distancing
requirements and things i think they
found it difficult to actually find a
space where where we could safely set up
right yeah so we were asked to stay away
from that whenever it goes to its its
summer configuration out onto the onto
the lawn i'll pass that on but um yeah i
wasn't here last friday but apparently
it was very well attended with people
estimating well over a thousand people
yeah now we were asked not to at that
point so um
you know we always obviously respect
that
absolutely we are getting additional
requests to go along to different groups
and speak so we can absolutely look at
arranging that and the key message i
keep saying to people though is and i
know it can be a bit of a hassle coming
in but you can't underplay the value of
a one-on-one with the planner and
they've got plenty of slots so people
might want to go collectively just to
watch numbers and room space but
certainly one-on-one can sit down and go
through that so
you know because i agree with you if
people want to do a submission be great
that they have enough time to do that so
if they can't get to a rental there's
not an event going to be local i'd
really encourage them to book a session
with the planner okay because i for one
will will indeed
will need a hand because i started out
of submission came to the first question
which said which number are you
submitting about and i completely have
no idea what number so
you can ring up so we've had um
been great but you can also ring through
so people been online got stuck or
whatever and they've been given that
assistance so there's plenty of resource
sitting there so tell anyone if they get
stuck or at all worried don't hesitate
ring get some help
okay so there's no
hard paper copies of it around
uh in terms of the plan yes no it's no
you'd have to download that you can
download it it's downloadable and you
can download it in sections but you'll
be doing that downloading and printing
off on your own computer okay
all right grape our meeting yesterday
was
cancelled due to covert
so that that didn't happen
and i had some notes here on the
mandeville village in the car park we've
discussed that already that's me
just to comment on and raise comments
this could they are valid concerns by
those sports club members
um that were they were built into
the msc strategy and vision that at the
heart of it it always will be a sports
club facility
and that the needs of the 14 clubs are
paramount over the wider community
because that's why the msc exists
the board also recognizes that sports
clubs don't generate enough revenue
through the facility
to maintain
the areas and stuff we want to do which
the council can't fund
therefore we need to
entice
the community and outside groups onto
the msc so we can get their money
basically
and it's it's a fine line of ensuring
that we stay true to the ethos of why
the msc was created in the first place
and i think
and we're talking about that all the
time at board level so but those those
older members who we owe a lot to for
the work they've done um you know we've
got to make sure that we listen and take
their concerns on board with regard to
the trees i only found out about it that
they were coming down at our last board
meeting which was only
a couple of weeks ago um and the reason
they're coming down not all of them
though so there's one line of trees
staying there's the two lines in behind
the first city
it's due to the the
the damage in the wind
so it's the because i see why we're
cutting down trees because i'm a bit of
a greenie now so
i if you cut them down you can't get
them back for a long time and but
and the thing is that even though the
trees are on the msc they're not owned
by the board so all trees on the
property reach them by the council and
when they come down we can't even sell
the firewood they the council take
everything away so the council owned
trees on our leased land
and those ones are coming down due to
concerns about they won't survive too
much more of high winds which i think
we're going to see more of
but again i do think that it was the
case between
our board and the council advising
neighbours of work going on that would
affect them
there has been concerns of
one vocal member of the community about
the noise coming out of mandeville on
weekends when the sports playing and
people leaving the sports club bar at
night time
who are mainly sports club members and
they have been met with that resident to
try and resolve those issues and that
was going well and i think it has it's
gone a little bit off track
um
and again they've cut down trees along
the old eastern pony boundary which has
opened up the entire subdivision to
mandeville so again part of our
strategic plan is how do we work with
the community around mandeville because
as we continue to develop it we're
conscious it's going to have an effect
like the rubber club are looking to put
in brand new lighting which are more
powerful than the lights they've got now
so when they go on into the winter
they're going to brighten up mandeville
significantly and so but they need that
to develop the game at mandeville but it
is how that impacts the residents
so
part of the board's strategy is to have
consultation with the community and rate
how they're going through
yearly customer feedback community
feedback and we've set targets on
on how satisfied club members clubs and
the community and stakeholders are with
the performance of the board so i think
we're trying to cover it from quite a
few areas so
yeah but they are they are concerned so
ray
chris brown and i met with that
particular client person well two of
them actually the one that's
on the end and in this other one about
um the trees and and their their issues
the lady on the end she's not quite so
worried about things there's just one or
two trees that she would like to see
removed because for safety the other
gentleman
doesn't want the trees all gone at all
but the the uh old microcarpas that are
close by they are actually their roots
and that are coming right over to their
house and and their ground and
everything else doesn't even so we're
going to be look getting a tree tack in
tree tree tech
and and they're going to mark the trees
that need to go
and so that's where we're up to at the
moment i spent quite a bit time with
that gentleman
and um
we left with qui with quite you know amy
roland and just explained to him because
he didn't know
that um there's a walking track round
that he just thought people were just
walking there but there is actually a
formed walking track so it's a whole lot
of things that he doesn't understand
that we need to just the board needs to
to deal with so that's where that is
quickly can i just say a couple of
things
thank you yeah yeah i i know the person
you're talking about uh uh reasonably
well i played bowls with them um
but um that that track that we're
talking about and under those trees
under locked down my grandchildren spent
a lot of time going through there and so
it's quite important to them and they're
going to be around around much longer
than what i am but under the district
plan
the proposed district plan mandeville is
most of it is going to be a large lot
residential zone which means there's
potential for it to
virtually double in size
and so
it's going to be quite uh huge
mandeville doesn't have a school doesn't
have a church doesn't have a community
hall and so the mandeville sports centre
is going to
have to look very carefully and i've got
a foot in both camps and and uh
it's i think there's going to be some
very um uh hard questions that will be
asked of the board in the near future so
um
good luck
yeah
well i'm going to be speedy because i'm
going to be at work in five hours so
um
the community trusts i've had their bbq
trailer we did a big renovation on it
it's all been wrapped it looks fantastic
um and they're having their christmas
grotto from the 17th of december through
the 25th
um
and
they
yeah we'll be looking for volunteers to
help out with that if anyone's available
um i've been helping opec with the water
tank project that they're going that
they're
embarking on um
somehow i've volunteered for that
don't quite know how that happened but
um
and then yeah i just wanted to mention
the um trees in pearson park that surely
earlier mentioned about them falling
over and the planting that they've done
in there so that's me
um i've got it all written out but
basically
we've been very busy with webinars and
zooms and three waters
and it's actually in go on the district
plan so it's actually really been
engulfing all of us so um
that's but there's been lots of other
stuff but i'll just send what what i've
done through um i'm sorry i've left it
sitting on the
bench
so i'll just send it yeah i know
it's all packed up ready to go i'll send
it through to you because i've got it on
oh my god i think i deleted it but i'll
look i'll i'm coming down tomorrow so
i'll give you one of those things too
so
get up the rear must be my turn
um
look since we haven't had a meeting
since
august
uh i have a litany of things written
down here which i will send to you all
and you can read or not or whatever
but just highlights i suppose
back in august you'll all note the
stadium y mccary opening that was 5 000
people
were there which over the day which was
fantastic
i have met with and discussed
things with various staff about
concerns over the
the dog signage and also a hookah domain
berm condition that has raised his ugly
head again so
hopefully we can get to the end of
that as well
there have as wendy rightly put a whole
bunch of zooms there's been a whole life
on zoom and there have been
lots of
meetings and discussions over three
waters and district plan
also notable during lockdown the coveted
welfare committee
reconvened and met regularly
weekly
to just make sure that everybody was
okay out there and it was actually
really
pleasantly surprising that the community
did in fact fare very well
it was pretty much business as usual
there were a couple things but by and
large this time around people knew what
to do so last time we had a situation
where we had a whole new
category of people that had never ever
needed to access any kind of help in a
system they didn't know what was out
there and if it was you know if it was
available for them and how to access it
and this time everybody kind of knew the
script so i think that we we saw
the benefit of that this time around so
there wasn't too much
too much strife out there really um we
were expecting a lot more
uh the
on the gcp front the um
there have been a
few meetings have gone under the bridge
since then but
we have just undertaken an mou with a
government for an urban growth
partnership which basically that's
similar to the greater christchurch
partnership but it will also now involve
two ministers of the crown with a view
to advancing the
decarbonization of transport increasing
resilience to natural hazards and
climate change accelerating provision of
quality affordable housing and improving
access to education employment and
services for the greater christchurch
region now why this matters to us is
because we are the second largest
metropolitan area in new zealand and we
don't have one of these partnerships but
there are other places smaller than us
and mostly in the north island that do
and what what this enables us to do is
actually have a seat at the table to be
heard a little bit more loudly and
clearly than we have been in the past
instead of being brushed aside so
that's believe it or not quite an
exciting development um the ymca youth
council they've had a couple meetings
since we've met last but one of the
exciting developments for that is we
have a new youth coordinator
who has been appointed emily belton
and she comes from bulls new zealand
actually guys perky ears up
and she's she's going to be fantastic
she's already gelling really well with
with the youth counselors
um
canterbury mayoral forum climate change
workshop
the reason i mention this is because
it's something that we we meet regularly
but only maybe like every quarter or six
months but it's the climate change
counselors across the 10 canterbury
councils and we get usually get a guest
speaker have a round table about sort of
the
the wins the challenges and initiatives
that everybody's doing which is a really
valuable
networking opportunity but the guest
speaker was trevor stuthbridge who's a
research director from ag research
and it was really interesting to hear
from him particularly given that ours is
a very rural ward with some water
challenges
and the climate change methane nitrate
question and it's actually good to know
that there's some research going on in
there it was kind of it was quite
fascinating actually
but um
the
yeah that's enough about all that but
the council meeting last september on
the september um just amongst topics
discussed
where in light of it investigations
undertaken on the oxford ini and
monitoring upgrades and their waste
water treatment plant options to resolve
sludge disposal
they decided that the unspent ini budget
be transferred to the wastewater
treatment options because that was the
where the most improvements were to be
had because um when they actually looked
i'm sorry ionia is um
influential for infiltration so it's
basically like water getting into the
pipes
like whether that be ground water rain
water whatever so they were like okay
are there cracks in our pipes where's
the extra water coming from so whenever
they actually
looked into that they found that
it wasn't as bad as they thought it was
and the money was actually better spent
in the wastewater treatment plant and
they have some
a good option to de-water the sludge so
it doesn't so it's not as heavy doesn't
have to be transported as far
and
it will result in cost savings and also
be environmentally better so
but you can read about that in the
report for
information anyhow but also the sixth
there has been the approval of a
six-month trial for flamingo e-scooters
so if you are
out and about in rengara kaya poi wooden
or pegasus they are going to drop up to
400 e-scooters in those places the trial
is going to run from either october
november
through till march and april
but not to worry there will be
geo-fencing restrictions for no-go
preferred parking no parking speed
restrictions and special access zones
um it'll cost a dollar to unlock and 38
cents per minute for general rates and
free to unlock and 30 cents per minute
for students gold card and community
service card holders i know you're all
chomping at the bit to try one others
out i'm sure
and hopefully well depending on how that
goes they will think about ruling it out
to other places like
who knows oxford may or may not get some
we'll see how they go don't know how you
feel about that but that's
yeah and then the
the
three waters on 28th of september i'm
sure you're all aware we unanimously
voted not in favor of the reform
um
this isn't a situation where we can say
we're opting out or not but we've given
feedback to say that the reform as it
stands as it's written
is not fit for purpose
and you'll also be aware that we
notified the district plan on the 20th
of september so the consultation of
course has begun
and other news for those who haven't
heard it i can finally i'm finally
allowed to tell you that myself and
neville atkinson have been appointed as
the elected representatives on the panel
on the hearings panel for the district
plan
therefore it might make a little bit
more sense to you now that i'm not
putting my hand up to
man stalls for district plan and whatnot
because i do need to be very careful
about
any kind of perceived conflicts or or
biases or anything like that when in
actual fact i have a very open mind on
all of it so
um but that's
quite excited to finally get that
notified and over the line and just get
on with it because it's been a long time
coming
the council meeting that we had
yesterday
um i regret to inform you all
we were talking about whether
rather that the motion was to um
go out for consultation for the district
walking and cycling plan
however whilst we have
voted
to go ahead and go out for consultation
waka kotahi have disappointingly led us
left us entirely high and dry they have
allocated us zero funding
which to which i did voice my great
displeasure may i say so
um
you know we so basically what that means
is whilst we're gonna go out and ask the
community
what their thoughts are on the network
and whatnot we can't actually give you
any major time frames or
anything like that we have the 563
500 budget that we have allocated which
is our 49
and the nzta have given us zilch towards
their 51 which we had every reason to
expect for them to give us which they
did not
have no idea why um
so yeah we've just got 563 000 for the
next three years to proceed with so
what
the thought was with the consultation
going ahead was more for us to
just feel that with the community the
prioritization of the projects and also
it's important for us to actually be
able to demonstrate for further funding
rounds
that we actually have a coherent plan
and that ready to go
from my point of view i find it
incredibly
disappointing that you know we've been
told that the nzta that waka kotahi are
are starting to focus on alternative
active modes of transport they want us
to do that we've done that and we still
didn't get anywhere so it's really
frustrating
so i'm sure that you all join me with
your frustration as well
and interestingly moving on from that
subject
yeah well they hit this i think what
probably delayed it was the fact that
they were waiting to get the funding and
whenever we got the funding package
presented to us we went wait what
i'm sorry
yeah
so i don't yeah
i'm
was it november or something yeah
so we thought even though we're kind of
not consulting on what we originally had
hoped for
we still feel that we need to know from
our community prioritization-wise
and
interestingly the um they're going to do
a container trial for the whistler
bridge protection so that's in lee's
valley in our ward
and so
that bridge is repeatedly washed out
and the gabby and protection that
they've used hasn't you know it just
keeps getting washed away and obviously
we're going to see more and more of this
so they're trying something a little bit
new
and going to try a new um
they're going to trial a new method of
stabilizing the bridge to keep it from
washing out by filling containers like
railway containers with gravel and and
burying them about a meter in and then
putting gravel up against them
it'll look a little bit different
hopefully it works but that's something
of interest and the draft parking
strategy proposal is has been okay to go
out to consultation and as was rightly
mentioned by shirley the speed limit
consultation is open right now until the
18th of october
it's been two months sorry for the long
report
it's just been passed to go out for but
yeah i don't have the dates for that yet
it's not live yet but the speed limit
one is so
questions
send this through to you
a couple of points on that i'm just
bringing up the other thing i'd like to
emphasize is that you can do hard copy
submissions so on that link there's a
downloadable form and certainly plenty
of people are doing that
at the drop-in sessions we've had so far
which has talked to a planner they've
been really well attended they've been
really busy we've actually had to amp up
the number of planners at those evening
sessions so sometimes just let people
know sometimes they will have a bit of a
weight we've got audrey there
um
you know moving people on and what we're
saying to planners if it's going to be a
longer conversation we might need to
re-book them to come in so they can have
a so we're trying to keep the time to
sort of 10 to 15 minutes but they have
been working well
yeah yep they have been they have been
really busy and always at the start we
get overwhelmed at the start because
everyone comes about 10 minutes early
and then it winds out a little bit later
so we have adjusted times but there is
still time if we feel like there's other
places you'd like us to be audrey is
coordinating that so
um but definitely people can do hard
copy submission like they do with
anything else if they need to
um and sorry i did just get a slightly
different type i got a
uh
email from j mcbride she obviously went
away and had a look at the mandeville
car park consent to see exactly where it
was at the current consent is for a
sealed and marked car park
yeah so
she's updated me on that it may be
amended from there but that's where it
stands there's at today
um so i don't know if there's any
questions about the district plan you're
all
all right
thank you mr jefferson i would just like
to remind members to please encourage
members of the community to apply for
the grant funding we on the
fourth month of the financial year and
we've only received one application
for the oxford ohoka area so
it would be highly appreciated if you
could just get the word out there i
would also like to advise that the
community boards youth development grant
fund epic is now receiving applications
and all the information is available on
the council website
thank you
right tia has just
said if you indicate now
tonight if you want to go out for a meal
and tear will
bring a few places and try and get
something organized
so
and let the board members know
what's that for us everybody's doing
that surely
okay
i know what you mean
you